what's popping voters it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
y'all spoilers coming your way for echo
on Disney plus because we are going to
be talking all about the show's ending
and what exactly could be coming next
for everyone's favorite Kingpin of crime
on the road to his next appearance in
Daredevil born again and how this could
pave the way for the Kingpin becoming
the mcu's newest Big Bad threat in
Spider-Man 4 so let's just dive into
this thing shall we and yo listen give
this video a quick like yeah because not
only does it help the heavy spoilers
Channel grow and reach new people but it
also helps me not get embarrassed in
front of Vanessa and you wouldn't want
to embarrass me in front of Vanessa now
would you would you H don't make me
break off your car door
now I'm just kidding or am I yes I am
because I'm pretty sure I would give
myself a hernia and several hemorrhoids
if I attempted to yank your car door off
its hinges I'm not that strong like I'm
pretty strong but I'm not that
strong
May now that's a good idea I could run
for mayor and that's pretty much how the
echo post credit scene went let's talk
about it because it very much sets up
some super exciting stuff for the future
of the MCU in particular street level
Marvel which is something that people
have been clamoring for for years now
because oh my Lord mayor Kingpin is
coming to make the Big Apple safe again
the end of the echo finale is very much
intended to tease an upcoming major
conflict for any and all people in New
York City who can make their body glow
and do superhuman things for the good of
the people that's right everybody the
internet rumors seem to be true the
devil's Reign is coming to the NYC of
the MCU all right so for those of you
who don't know Devil's Reign is an
intense event from the Marvel Comics
that shows Wilson Fisk finally become
mayor of New York City a mayor that has
promised to deal with a long-standing
inequality that has plagued the good
people of the city long enough
superhumans because you see superhumans
are scary and cannot be trusted so why
should they be able to run around using
those dangerous superpowers as illegal
Vigilantes what makes superhumans so
damn special that they get a free pass
to do whatever they want without
repercussions all while good hardworking
Americans are forced to live on a much
more strict set of rules just because
they don't have superpowers that's not
fair so to address this inequality the
Kingpin introduces the Powers Act a
piece of legislation that forbids any
superhuman to use their po for
vigilantism because vigilantism is
illegal while also giving Wilson fist
control over the Thunderbolts as well as
an army of soldiers called his
Thunderbolt units to lawfully arrest any
and all superheroes found violating this
law so this all being said you can
probably see why Wilson fisk's upcoming
run for mayor is super appropriate
especially considering what Marvel
Studios has been doing with their recent
projects to tease the upcoming chaos
growing in the MCU like there's a reason
why projects like Spider-Man no way home
home and Miss Marvel have begun to show
us a strong wave of fear and xenophobia
growing across the world as
organizations like damage control start
abusing their power and authority to
arrest even the youngest among the
superpowered populace for using their
superpowers and with the ending of
secret Invasion sending the entire world
on high alert against superpowered alien
foreigners from Beyond it's only a
matter of time before all the
superpowered alien migrants on Earth are
also targeted by Val and the American
government next even the superpowered
beings that look like aliens like the
sub aquatic sovereignty of the tyoon who
can easily be mistaken for the cre race
and one of the main reasons why I
believe Marvel Studios is starting to
let superpowered xenophobia grow at this
particular point in the MCU is simple
the X-Men are on the way I mean yeah
it's quite clear that Marvel Studios is
very much holding a mirror to our real
life world by trying to get people to
see that people who Round Up innocent
people and put them in cages just
because they're different are bad people
they're also taking the opportunity to
establish that the MCU Earth is now a
very fearful place and when the world is
afraid it is much easier to be angry and
hateful towards groups that they
personally do not understand because
that is the core of the mutant narrative
in the X-Men comics with the mutant
Brotherhood leader Magneto rebelling
against the world's fearful oppression
of mutants by becoming a supremacist
himself and the mutant Charles Xavier
forever looking for ways to broker peace
between mutated superhumans and regular
Humanity so Wilson Fisk becoming mayor
and enacting the Powers Act to even
further boost damage controls efforts to
round up even more genetically mutated
super beings like Miss Marvel and
Spider-Man definitely feels like it is
very much serving the MCU to establish
the future grievances of X-Men arch
nemesis Magneto a man who has seen
firsthand exactly where such
persecutions can lead because that dude
went through the Holocaust and the
Holocaust sucked so bad the MCU adapting
and introd producing the Powers Act from
the devil's Reign story arc now
definitely makes sense as it very much
feels like a rebirth of the sovia
Accords introduced in Captain America
Civil War during Daredevil's much
anticipated appearance in 2022 She-Hulk
attorney at law Matt Murdoch mentions
that as of the modern day of the MCU the
sovia Accords have been repealed for at
least a little while now allowing for
superheroes to continue to fight crime
without being directed by the federal
government or the United Nations as a
whole however this is a new day in the
MCU and since Civil War I generals Steve
Rogers and Tony Stark are no longer
around now is the greatest time for the
political entities of the world to try
at another sovia Accords again because
they know that they're not going to get
any push back from Captain Rogers or
Iron Man Two massively influential
public figures responsible for saving
countless lives throughout the entire
universe but why would MCU Kingpin want
to enact the Powers Act in the first
place I mean yeah we do know that
politicians playing on people's fears
and acting like their candidacy or
leadership is the only solution to
abating those fears is a classic
political maneuver employed to this day
but I think it's still good to question
what exactly Beyond just that political
tactic could be driving Big Willie to
want to round up superpowered beings in
the first place well I think we just saw
that reasoning in the Echo finale
specifically when mayia used her cool
new genetic abilities to tap into
kingpin's mind and enter his most
vulnerable memories without his
permission because right after this
happens Kingpin grabs Maya and demands
to know what that superpowered witch
just did to him and how a disabled woman
that he's known since she was a
vulnerable little girl could suddenly
develop superpowers that allowed her to
take down Fisk and his goons with far
less effort than he's ever seen her used
before in short Wilson Fisk is scared
throughout his entire life Fisk has used
his physical strength to muscle his way
to the very top of the New York City
underworld but while the superpowered
Avengers were doing their thing fighting
the more flashy world-ending bad guys
like your Ultron and your thanoses the
big bads of the criminal underworld have
been living pretty free from the eyes of
the superhero Community as a whole for a
very long time in the MCU however now
that the rate at which superpowered
beings are popping up in the world has
increased dramatically over time street
level heroes like Spider-Man Clinton
Barton's Ronin Daredevil Luke Cage
Jessica Jones ironfist Etc have started
to get more and more superpowered help
from newcomers like you know shunqi Miss
Marvel Kate bishop moonight and of
course the greatest hero of all time
leate Frog who have been inspired by The
Avengers enough to step in and help in
their own way I mean damn there's so
many superheroes now that Luke Jacobson
can make a comfortable living designing
and maintaining super suits for all of
these fresh new fighters of crime like
it's truly A Brave New World so while
I'm sure Wilson Fisk was worried about
that super superpowered threat before to
some degree Ekko using her powers to
send him back to his most traumatic
memory thus rendering him so vulnerable
and Powerless definitely seems to have
lit a fire under Wilson fisk's large
white ass because the Kingpin is
starting to feel like his crown is in
Jeopardy because his own raw strength is
quickly starting to get outmatched as
MCU genetic Evolution continues to take
its course and makes new superpowered
beings he's threatened by the emergence
of these various new breeds of mutations
making the previously dominant human
race inferior and I'm pretty sure he's
not the only underworld gang leader that
is worried about this because I'm sure
entities like the 10 Rings the power
broker and Hydra are also sharing the
kingpin's concerns as well and will
probably end up working together with
him to some degree with Val probably
uniting all these super villains
together so this all being said you can
pretty much squarely blame mayor
kingpin's upcoming persecution of
superhuman Vigilantes squarely on Echo
in my opinion because her mind
infiltrating powers has for sure made
Uncle Willie scared and angry however I
have a funny feeling that by the end of
Wilson fisk's reign of terror over the
enhanced of New York City it's going to
be revealed that Wilson Fisk himself has
been a mutant this entire time and he
didn't even know it because I don't know
if you guys have noticed but
um big Wilson is uh abnormally strong
and resilient like to a crazy degree
like not only can this dude pull off and
weaponize a car door at the blink of an
eye but he has also inexplicably tanked
an explosion from one of Hawkeye's
arrows and Maya's Point Blank bullets to
the freaking eyeball like a godamn g
this is a man who has eaten his weedies
and the last time I checked Wilson Fisk
hasn't been exposed to any super soldier
serums spider bites or gamma radiation
to mutate his DNA so the only real
logical explanation I can think of for
the Kingpin super strong and resilient
biology is for him to have been enhanced
through his natural genetics through the
Daredevil TV series we know how
traumatic Wilson's childhood was in the
Fisk household and how much that trauma
formed Wilson's entire cruel and
controlling personality but I think that
trauma could have formed more than just
that I have a feeling that kingpin's
resilience towards all of the abuse that
he endured during his puberty years
could have activated his mutant Gene
early and caused Kingpin to become a
mini mutant super soldier in his own way
able to withstand things that would kill
most people because his father always
wanted him to toughen up Kingpin finding
out that he has actually secretly been
the very thing that he's been
persecuting as mayor would be such a
dope way to wrap up that Devil's Reign
story arc while also furthering the
mutant narrative for the inevitable
mutant Saga after Secret Wars but
anyways this all being said the recent
Spider-Man 4 rumors are for sure
starting to make sense now as Internet
scooper at cryptic 4wal has recently
said that their sources have hinted that
Spider-Man 4 will be treated like a
street level Civil War event so with the
confirmation that the MCU is indeed
seeking to adapt this Devil's reain
storyline from the comics the Powers Act
possibly being introduced in Daredevil
born again will likely lead all the
street level heroes of the MCU to band
together to fight against kingpin's
Rising superhuman xenophobia Luke Cage
Jessica Jones Ekko Daredevil the good
Iron Fist Miss Marvel moonight the Young
Avengers and more however since Sony is
still only letting Marvel Studios borrow
Spider-Man for a certain number of
appearances as per their contract having
all these heroes team up in a Spider-Man
movie is probably the most realistic way
that we'll ever get to see Spider-Man
finally face off against Kingpin in the
MCU because Spider-Man can't really
appear in any non-sony approved MCU
projects so while some people
understandably would want a Spider-Man 4
to be a much more Spider-Man focused
taale with a much smaller scale Marvel
Studios has to really save Spider-Man
appearances for events that would be the
most worth it and a Spider-Man Daredevil
team up is one of the most requested
things from MCU fans right now but do
you guys know what would be the dopest
thing about Kingpin potentially being
the villain of Spider-Man 4 would be
getting to see the Kingpin merge with
the Venom symbiote just like we saw him
do in the comics in the Spider-Man 100th
Anniversary Special from 2014 because
don't y'all forget now Spider-Man No Way
Holmes post credit scene had Venom leave
behind some of his goo as a tip to
Eddie's exasperated bartender and good
Lord was that goo on the move so I can
for sure see Spider-Man 4 having Peter
go through a much different black suit
Spider-Man Arc by letting him unleash
his Dark Side against a mayor Kingpin
who wants nothing more than to unmask
Mysterio killer and take him off the
streets permanently and if I were to
guess Marvel Studios is probably
thinking that by having all these other
street level heroes join Spider-Man 4 to
fight Kingpin could serve the black suit
Spider-Man narrative by showing
Spider-Man that he doesn't have to rely
on the Symbiotes dark power to fight his
battles alone kind of like how we saw in
the Spider-Man 2 video game because if
there's one thing a symbiote likes to do
it's make Peter Parker isolate himself
from all the support systems in his life
so after he tears the black suit
symbiote off of his body I can
definitely see Peter Parker proudly
teaming up with all of these street
level Defenders to take on a Kingpin who
has taken Peter symbiote for for himself
because while Kingpin is indeed strong I
don't think he feels like he's strong
enough and the Venom symbiote would be
the perfect performance enhancing drug
for the most dedicated Kingpin of crime
but anyways that is it for this
follow-up video on the echo post credit
scene what do you guys think of the post
credit scene and where do you guys think
the MCU will be heading from here let us
know in the comment section below but
anyways you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter Instagram
YouTube or wherever I am on the internet
especially on the guard of the paly
podcast where me my friends Whitney van
Lingham and Tommy Beck told talk about
all the latest and nerd stuff in a
really fun way because we're all friends
and we just love being you know having
fun with with Marvel stuff and and nerd
stuff in general so come on down if you
like fun but most importantly follow
heavy spoilers here on YouTube and when
you do make sure you hit that
notification Bell so that you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video but again thank you guys so much
for watching you guys are amazing I love
you guys so much and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye